i do think that women want gentlemen i
do i think that they i think that those
women that buy into this nonsense all
the time and hear all this nonsense
about how oh when a guy opens a door for
you they're just trying to make you feel
small no honey they're trying to be a
jump he knows he knows that when he
opened the door for you that you could
if you wanted to you've got arms you can
open it yourself he's trying to be
respectful most women absolutely do want
that and most women want a man who can
defend himself most women want a man who
cares about taking care of himself and
his family you know they want a man they
don't want a boy they don't want a boy
who needs a safe space they want a man
and they've been trained that that's a
bad thing somehow and some of them take
the bait and you know what winds up to
those people those women wind up very
unhappy
people say you afraid to get canceled
i'm like no not i'm truly not even a
little bit i mean yeah would it be
annoying if i tweet something out and
they suspend you and then you can't po
you know it's annoying and it is a
symptom of a disease don't get me wrong
this desire to suppress
by you know the mob this desire to say
oh you think differently like look what
was labeled misinformation most of what
was labeled misinformation the last two
years wound up being accurate
information let's be honest and now you
can't you know call a man a man a woman
what biology ceases to matter words
cease to matter the word female has been
now it's gotta you know everybody's got
gotta be made to feel good about
themselves so we gotta change that word
in the dictionary you know it's all
about appeal it's all emotional they
wanna hold the left now seems to want a
whole world that's just subjective
nothing's grounded in reality and
nothing's grounded in facts and there's
a reason for that because in the land of
reality and facts they lose they never
come to the table with facts they never
come to the table with policies that
actually work they come to the table
with feelings they come to the table
that's not fair that's not just you know
redistribute the wealth and all of this
like oh you know we need to create a
fair society and and in the process they
create a society a society where people
are out of work where people can't
afford to fill their gas tanks where
people are struggling where people view
each other as the enemy where community
and family disappear
i mean all of these things where crime
is on the rise where
they they break stuff in the process of
trying to create what's fair it's all
language game but i'm not interested in
the world in the land of oz you know i'm
not looking to go over the rainbow and
sit in the little pot of gold that
doesn't exist
so
i'm comfortable in the space sound man
i'm very as you may have noticed yeah
how do you really feel i can't i'm not
reading you here what's going on here
really should be more blonde with you
dave i really should
so i want to back up to something that
you said a minute or two ago about some
of the things that you talk about
besides politics you mentioned
men and you mentioned relationships
you know i toured with jordan peterson
for a year and a half and he was always
a large portion of his audience was was
males who were trying to you know stand
up straight with their shoulders back
get their lives in order and it does
seem like we have this like dearth in
society of men
that have their [ __ ] together basically
that are kind of living the right way to
find a woman or find a dude or whatever
but to live like a full
life it seems worse somehow it seems
worse for men
than women right now do you think that's
fair to say and what do you think that
what do you think's going on there well
i think there's been a demonization of
men you know and i think feminism you
know and when i say feminism i don't
mean feminism as it was intended you
know a lot of the founding feminists
were pro-life i mean it was a very
different vision they had they were
talking about you know equality of
opportunity they were talking about a
society where women had the chance to
succeed removing those very legitimate
barriers that existed for women at the
time um and it was it was a very
pro-life movement as i said i'm talking
about the feminism of today how it's
been morphed how it's been taken over by
the left and now it's like it's
empowering somehow for women to be
[ __ ] it's empowering for women to you
know to rag on men you saw what happened
to kavanaugh at that disgraceful i mean
they just tore that man down with no
evidence they were just they've decided
they made a decision about who he was
this idea that men you know are bad or
oh men should take a back seat and be
quiet and let the women talk this idea
of toxic masculinity and oftentimes
what's referred to as toxic masculinity
is just men being gentlemen
men wanting to take care of themselves
and take care of their families yes men
being strong so i take all of these
things on and i think that men in many
ways have it harder and this is near and
dear to my heart because i'm raising a
son you know i'm raising a son at a time
where men are too easily demonized where
boys on college campuses are being told
to sit down and shut up it happens all
the time where they're told oh take a
bad seat let the women talk or their you
know sexual harassment charges just
because you're charged with something
now means you're guilty if you're a guy
so this is all near and dear to my heart
i think feminism has in many ways
damaged men and damaged women you know i
played a clip the other day on my show
of a woman out there talking about you
know how it was empowering for her to be
[ __ ] and you know was the patriarchy's
fault that everything that happened to
her was the fault effect of the
patriarchy and you know all this
nonsense and i'm like you know they
they've really done a disservice to
women
women who now you know women who now
think it's it's shameful to be a
housewife
why
it's shameful to be or being a mom isn't
being a mom is the most important job i
have it's the most wonderful rewarding
important job that i have it was that
was my superpower right carrying a baby
that was my super they've they've robbed
women of all these and now they're
robbing them of more right they're
taking their trophies they're taking all
of their oh woman of the year it doesn't
go to biological women anymore we've got
to make everybody feel welcome so
i think feminism has done a huge
disservice in short to men and to women
and what should really exist is mutual
respect people who respect themselves
who care about you know themselves who
are free thinking individuals and who
respect each other and that's been lost
and i think walked all over by feminism
of modern day feminists i should say
there there's obviously so many weird
parts of this i mean the idea that the
people who are championing women are
literally championing a guy with a penis
i mean leah thomas has a penis that's
just a fact uh connor my director over
here mentioned the other day why is he
or she's such a good swimmer because
maybe it acts as a propeller i thought
that that was pretty i thought that that
was pretty clever um
but amazing but but the people the it's
i mean it's good it's good but the
people who
were championing women are now
championing this guy girl whatever you
want to say uh as the winner and i think
it is my belief that i think women want
regular dudes i i think they want those
guys that open the door and do those
gentlemanly things and actually take
care of themselves the other meme on
this one is that every other week one of
daily beast or salon or one of these
idiotic websites write how working out
is now part of the alt-right you know
the far right is using fitness as a tool
to recruit
right it's like all of these things
would that would make you feel empowered
as a person right all of these things
health and wellness being fit feeling
strong you know wanting a strong man
beside you wanting a gentleman you know
being comfortable in your own skin these
are all things you know why because they
want a society of dependence right they
want you weak they want you subservient
they want you feeling unhappy with
yourself so now you have to what maybe
go live in the metaverse and maybe a big
tech guy can go make a bunch of money
off of it because you're too afraid to
enter the real world
don't forget the prescription pills
don't forget the prescription pills
exactly right i was just going to get to
that they want you chronically ill
because then you're a repeat customer
for big pharma and this idea of being
healthy and fortified and that's very
threatening to a lot of the ideologies
espoused by the left and a lot of people
they love and they you know change
dollars with oftentimes or whatever
so
in terms of big pharma i mean yeah so
yeah
this sense of personal responsibility
this is their enemy this is their number
one enemy and i do think that women want
gentlemen i do i think that they i think
that those women that buy into this
nonsense all the time and hear all this
nonsense about how oh when a guy opens a
door for you they're just trying to make
you feel small no honey they're trying
to be a jump he knows he knows that when
he opened the door for you that you
could if you wanted to you've got arms
you can open it yourself he's trying to
be respectful most women absolutely do
want that and most women want a man who
can defend himself most women want a man
who cares about taking care of himself
and his family you know they they want a
man they don't want a boy they don't
want a boy who needs a safe space they
want a man and they've been trained that
that's a bad thing somehow and some of
them take the bait and you know what
winds up to those people those women
wind up very unhappy they want to very
unhappy very very unhappy in life
because they're listening to this
nonsense and wind up alone oftentimes
because they've bought the story they've
bought the story so i think it's a lot
of it is about
it's not you know rejecting modern day
feminism is about embracing female
empowerment it's not about tearing it
down it's about saying you it's it's you
you dress [ __ ] you attract the wrong
kind of guy that's on you that's on you
own your own decisions your own choices
and what is the result of those choices
own it all and you'll feel some control
over your own life for a change if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell